what about dodge coin or dogecoin
everybody's jerking off to this one
last couple this is the original this is
the original mean coin
yeah people understand the coin is old
jackson paul jackson polymer thing was
the name one he made it
keys are burnt nobody runs it there's
hardly any github repos on it meaning
people aren't developing
it it was literally designed as a
joke yeah but like there was no
like
in intention to come in like oh we're
gonna create some no it's like
i'm gonna make fun of this and we're
gonna do dogecoin and it's created a
life of his own like believe it or not
like
there you just even as of two years ago
there used to be dogecoin
conferences in vancouver like the the
culture behind dogecoin is massive like
it's people
really don't understand the power of the
meme of dogecoin like if you're not
if you don't understand memes if you
don't understand like how
memes shape ideologies would shape
reality then you really don't understand
hey the world how it works and b
specifically how the crypto world works
so basically it's a joke i mean if you
want to play the joke then get it if you
if you're smarter than stay away from it
you